[Musique]
dans un sens comme dans l'autre
des périphériques surchargé et au dessus
des dizaines de piétons un peu fatigué
si vous pensez de tout cela m'était cher
monsieur je vais tellement et agressif
que ça passera pas à la télé dans le
métro
[Musique]
dur dur on peut plus marcher tellement
qu'on en a marre quoi ras-le-bol courage
demain est un autre jour pour bien
circuler dans la capitale aujourd'hui ne
valait être ingénieux et ne pas avoir
plus de deux roues sport parisien
pour les grèves c'est toute la journée
il a donc fallu pédaler patiner et
parfois suer à grosses gouttes pour
aller travailler
vous allez devenir hyper sportif avec la
grève ban n'a pas vraiment le choix on
peut au moins leur dire merci pour ça
stoller set gagné
les journées sont durs après le
covoiturage la nouvelle tendance
aujourd'hui c'était le commodo rage à
subir des problèmes de la grève aux
collègues bassem chercher alors vous en
pensez quoi du deux roues ça mais ça va
vite
[Musique]